and earlier today i sat down with the
russian ambassador to the uk audrey
keelin and i started by asking him what
message it sent to the world about how
serious russia is about climate change
when president putin chose not to attend
in person
well i think that the uh assessments
will be given after it will be over of
course but uh in the meantime uh what i
can say as an ambassador in this country
is that
of course it has been it took place in a
right time it has alerted uh very much
uh governments uh
private industry people in the countries
about importance of the problem it has
raised awareness
about the the problem
uh which is which is good i think uh as
for my country uh i will say that uh the
government has taken very serious
program
in october this year which is about a
low carbon emission of social economic
development by the year 2050
and there is a target of the year 2060
when we would like to reach the carbon
emission neutrality
it doesn't mean that it can happen
earlier but it will depend uh on
technologies uh on uh financement and on
the balance
between all these issues this program
has been presented by the vice prime
minister and we have very important
figures from the government and industry
in glasgow who are explaining what what
has happened but it is the symbolism as
well isn't it this message to the world
of the attendance of the president of
the russian federation himself and i
mean there are some suggestions that
perhaps president putin doesn't take
climate change quite as seriously as he
should let me read you a quotation
from him from 2017
where he talks about the causes of
climate change
say they're caused by changes of global
character cosmic changes some invisible
moves in the galaxy that doesn't seem to
accept that
they're man-made that they're
anthropogenic
uh we are very uh very much alert to the
whole issue because of the temperature
the rise of temperature in russia is
going quicker than in many other
countries
and as i said uh the uh program has been
uh done uh quickly in october just on
the eve of
the glasgow summit but it was preceded
also by the rome summit of g20 and some
world leaders decided to present the
pledges some decided not to present they
trusted
other people to it so in our case it was
a very high level of the presentation
but it is not i wouldn't say that it's
not very important to advertise the
program to the others we are doing just
uh we're simply doing it what we
intended to do
but what about the goals you mentioned
there net zero by 2060 not 2050 from
russia not signed up to the methane
reduction program and indeed on coal
not going to phase that out entirely
does that not show a lack of urgency no
no no uh the
uh the difficulty is that there is a
very low knowledge about uh
what we are doing really
the uh balance of our energy production
is really green
uh it is 40
of green energy
of hydro energy solar energy uh plus
plus others and atomic energy nuclear
energy 40 in the balance if you add add
gas to it it will make about 86 percent
very high figure you will not find a
similar figure in germany for instance
it is close to united states united
states is about 76 percent of green
energy so we are a very low production
of coal at the moment and we continue to
do that another figure which is
important uh during last 20 years it is
each year we are reducing emission of
green gases by 2.7
it is higher than another seven
countries so it is high figure let me
ask you then about gas and gas supply
and how dependent europe is upon the
supply of russian gas and it's been said
that russia is restricting supplies it's
flowing a bit more now i know
restricting supplies to western europe
to first and foremost get fast approval
for the vast nordstrom 2 pipeline but
also to put political pressure on the
west well i heard about that and this is
not very much truth and not at all
probe it has a lot of responsibility and
its prime responsibility lays inside
russia
we have had a very cold winter uh last
year and very hot summer and so the
storage uh capacities are at a low point
in russia as well as in europe so the
primary task for gas program was to
fulfill our own domestic storage
capacities plus the government is now
making the program of
gasification of uh
illuminated regions so it needs also a
lot of efforts from gas probe by
yesterday uh as it was announced earlier
gas probe has fulfilled this task
domestic task it it is now increasing
its uh
pipes increasing its pipe supplies to
europe and it is now doing it in the
four storages in germany and in the one
in austria so russia would like to see
the approval of north stream two as
quickly as possible the construction is
complete it just needs that approval uh
well it will be funny if i will going to
to contradict this point of course we do
why not we have the consortium of
european countries has constructed it
has invested it and a lot of efforts and
a lot of money and of course we
anticipate that it will be approved
now you'll be aware of uh christopher
steele who came to notoriety uh being
involved in former um security uh
services agents from the uk who came to
notoriety for
amongst other things
developing the uh the the dossier during
the uh during the uh trump
uh campaign in the united states now
we've interviewed him recently and uh
he has a theory that the ultimate goal
of russia is to actually collapse and
that's the word he uses collapse the
european union
you know could the issue of gas could
what's happening on the border of
belarus and poland and the baltic
nations could that be be part of that
programme
uh well i i'm
i will say i'm amazed and surprised
about the reaction uh in the european
union what is happening over there
uh it is about uh
two or thousand of immigrants who are
now gathered or perhaps four thousand
because estimations of bbcsa and the
other sources a bit different
about
four to two thousand immigrants are now
at the border between poland and belarus
uh simply saying that uk is accepting in
a good day when a calais uh of the
strait of calais is calm about a
thousand of immigrants and all together
it's about twenty thousand twenty
thousand of immigrants that has been
received peacefully in the united
kingdom this year only so what is what
is all about it but it's more than two
thousand coming from belarus lithuania
already has accepted four thousand
uh no no no no figures are much lower
first of all is that uh it should be
humanitarian principles of humanitarian
law that should be applicable here then
of course a matter of good will as well
so there is a low laws in the european
union and international laws about
immigrants the problem is blown up of
course and it is very controversial when
european union was dealing with turkey
of course it preferred to pay to turkey
to to leave this immigrants inside the
country and remember the history about
hungary and immigrants which were coming
via romania everybody was blaming
hungary not for not receiving the
immigrants
but president lukashenko of belarus is
laying on extra flights to places like
baghdad he's encouraging the migrants to
come to minsk and then
in part taking them to that border to
put pressure upon the european union now
russia
president putin could have a word this
is one of russia's key allies president
putin could have a word could he not
with president lukashenko and say
please stop that
and they talked uh but
and they talked i have no notion uh
about this subject how they discuss it
uh but i think uh absolutely that the
it is strange to see polish troops 12
000 of polish troops tanks and the
others sealing the borders that just
simply not to help these people
can i ask you just broadly does does
russia recognize president lukashenka as
having been
elected of course in western europe
we regard it as a fraudulent election
that he's he's not there by popular vote
uh
it is wrong exception uh the president
of kashenko is very popular in its own
country and you will see it uh there is
a change of constitution things will
change i do not know when and so far uh
you'd better ask about this ambassador
of belarus
but his popularity is unquestionable
absolutely let's get on to uk russia
relations because we know that uh prime
minister boris johnson and president
putin recently had a phone call it was
last month
in which
boris johnson said that of course the
two nations need to work together but
there are still significant problems and
what i'd like to ask you ambassador is
from the russian perspective
what does the uk and other nations what
what do we have to do to normalize these
relations from from the uk perspective
of course it's dealing with issues which
we'll get onto in more detail in a
moment to the salisbury poisonings the
cyber attacks
from the russian perspective is it in
part stop accusing us of doing those
things
uh you are right uh president putin and
uh prime minister johnson spoke on the
eve of lago conference and they spoke
for about 45 minutes
they discussed uh several subjects and
they fully agreed about once one issue
that the relationship between united
kingdom and the russian federation are
not one that they want
it's an important constitution it's a
desire of both leaders
to bring a relationship between the two
countries to a new and a better level of
course
i think that there was a good chance
when uk has withdrawn from a
european union
for the united kingdom to establish new
and better relationship with russia it
gives many new opportunities also for
businessmen as well and i'm talking to
british businessmen and they're
saying uh they're telling me that
for them of course it will be better to
deal
in business with russia than to go very
far to the east for uh the terrains that
do not bring immediate rewards and so on
and to talk to european countries and to
deal business with russian businessmen
and with russia of course so
you seem to be saying that uh you see
russia sees an opportunity for a uk
russia trade deal these much sought
post-brexit trade deals
much much better of course we do believe
that there are opportunities for
mutually beneficial trade and mutually
beneficial business and for better uh
exchanges between us and we are
expecting that british government will
come to this conclusion pretty soon are
there any talks even at the informal
level taking place on that issue on a
trade deal very very slow no not on the
uh not on the trade deal not on the
trade deal because british government uh
some years ago has abolished all the
governing bodies we did have a joint
commission on trade and we did have a
joint agency on energy so all structures
has been abolished by british government
well i mean you know what would help
restore these relations is that attack
in 2018 on british soil a poisoning
attack killed a british citizen attacked
two russian citizens
and carried out by by russian agents
there are now three names we all know
them three names identified by the
investigating authorities in the united
kingdom and boris johnson says
hand them over for justice
well this approach is not serious uh i
know that uh in this country the
criminal stories uh in uh
the style of james bond are very popular
of course and they are appearing in the
newspapers they are being repeated in
westminster and the government has to
react if you would like to put it on a
serious basis there are views there are
possibilities of a serious exchange on
the level of the experts on the level of
special service and so on but british
government is constantly denying uh this
option of doing it what about access to
the suspects either you know perhaps
in the russian embassy here in london or
allow
british police to to interview them in
russia
i think it is in the films
well ambassador it's a very serious
point is to say
british citizen has died others have
been
authorities are perfectly aware how to
deal with this not through the
newspapers but how to deal with these
issues properly and uh and in a right
way americans i know how to do this i do
believe that breeze i know it as well
and the other issue which one imagines
could start to normalize or certainly
improve relations is the issue that uh
that i know that you've had discussion
with
discussions about when you were called
in by the foreign office this issue of
cyber attacks cyber attacks emanating
from russia perhaps not necessarily
traced all the way back to the russian
state yes but you are hosting those that
carry out these of course yes uh
everybody is accusing us but the
proponents of the re-evil group were
arrested yesterday as i understand so
among
them are two romanians and one ukrainian
as i understand